but the neutrality one is really
interesting because uh that's basically
a summary
of the discussions that are going on
underneath it would be amazing if uh
like I should be honest I don't look at
the talk page often I don't it would be
nice somehow if there was a kind of a
summary in the in this Banner way of
like
this lots of Wars have been fought on
this here land for this here paragraph
It's really interesting yeah I hadn't
thought of that because we one of the
things I do spend a lot of time thinking
about these days and you know people
have found it we're moving slowly but
you know we are moving thinking about
okay these tools exist are there ways
that this stuff can be useful to our
community because a part of it is we we
do approach things in a non-commercial
way in a really deep sense it's like
it's it's been great that Wikipedia has
become very popular but really we're
just we're a community whose hobby is
writing an encyclopedia that's first and
if it's popular great if it's not okay
we might have trouble paying for more
servers but it'll be fine and so how do
we help the community use these tools
what are the ways that these tools can
support people and one example I never
thought about I'm gonna start playing
with it is you know feed in the article
and feed in the talk page and say can
you suggest some warnings in the article
based on the conversation to the top
page I think it might might be good at
that it might get it wrong sometimes but
again if it's reasonably successful at
doing that and you can say oh actually
yeah it does suggest
um you know the neutrality of this has
been disputed on a section that has a
seven page discussion in the back that
might be useful I don't know what you're
playing with I mean some more color to
the
not neutrality but also
the amount of emotion Laden in the
exploration of this particular part of
the topic yeah it might it might
actually help you look at more
controversial Pages uh like on you know
a page on uh war in Ukraine or a page on
Israel and Palestine there could be
parts that everyone agrees on and
there's parts that are just like tough
tough the hard part it would be nice to
when looking at those beautiful long
articles to know like all right let me
just take in some stuff where everybody
agrees on I could give an example that I
haven't looked at in a long time but I
was really pleased with what I saw at
the time so the the discussion was that
they're building something in Israel
and for their own political reasons uh
one side calls it a wall hearkening back
to Berlin Wall apartheid the other calls
it a security fence so we can understand
quite quickly if we give it a moment's
thought like okay I understand why
people would have this this grappling
over the language like okay you want to
highlight the negative aspects of this
and you want to highlight the positive
aspects so you're going to try and
choose a different name and so there was
this really fantastic Wikipedia
discussion on The Talk page how do we
word that paragraph to talk about the
different naming it's called This by
Israel is called this by Palestinians
and that how you explain that to people
could be quite charged right you could
easily explain oh there's this
difference and it's because this side's
good and this side's bad and that's why
there's a difference or you could say
actually let's just let's try and really
stay as neutral as we can and try to
explain the reasons so you may come away
from it with with a concept uh oh okay I
understand what this debate is about now
and uh just the term
israel-palestine conflict
um is still the title of a page at
Wikipedia But the word conflict is
something that is a charged word of
course yeah because uh from the
Palestinian side or from uh certain
sides the word conflict doesn't
accurately describe the situation
because if you see it as a genocide One
Way genocide is not a conflict because
to that to to people that uh discuss
that challenge the word conflict they
see you know conflict is when there's
two equally powerful sides fighting yeah
yeah no it's it's hard and you know in
in a number of cases so this is this
actually speaks to a slightly broader
phenomenon which is there are a number
of cases where there is no one word that
can get consensus
and in the body of an article that's
usually okay because we can explain the
whole thing you can come away with an
understanding of why each side wants to
use a certain word but there are some
aspects like the pay tests have a title
um so you know there's that same thing
with
um certain things like photos you know
it's like well there's different photos
which one's best a lot of different
views on that but at the end of the day
you need the lead photo because there's
one slot for a lead photo
categories is another one
um so at one point I have no idea if
it's in there today but I don't think so
um
I was listed in uh you know kind of
American entrepreneurs fine American
atheists and I said hmm that doesn't
feel right to me like just personally
it's true I mean I wouldn't wouldn't
disagree with the objective fact of it
but when you click the category and you
see sort of a lot of people who are you
might say American atheist activist
because that's their big issue so
Madeline Murray O'Hare or various famous
people who uh Richard Dawkins who make
it a big part of their public argument
and persona but that's not true of me
it's just like my private personal
belief it doesn't really it's not
something I campaign about so it felt
weird to put me in the category but like
what category would you put you know and
and do you need that guy in this case I
was I argued it doesn't need that
catalog that's not I don't speak about
it publicly except incidentally from
time to time I don't campaign about it
so it's weird to put me with this group
of people and that argumentary today I
hope not just because it was me but
um but categories can be like that where
you know you're either in the category
or you're not and sometimes it's a lot
more complicated than that and is it
again we go back to is it undue wait uh
you know if
uh someone who is now prominent in
public life and generally considered to
be a good person uh
was convicted of something let's say DUI
when they were young we normally in
normal sort of discourse we don't think
oh this person should be in the category
of American criminals because you think
a criminal yeah technically speaking
it's against the law to drive under the
influence of alcohol and you were
arrested and you
spent a month in prison or whatever but
it's odd to say that's a criminal so it
just says an like example in this area
is
um
Mark Wahlberg Marky Mark that's what I
always think of a mask because that was
his first sort of famous name who I
wouldn't think should be listed as in
the category American criminal even
though he did he was convicted of uh
quite a bad crime when he was a young
person but we don't think of him as a
criminal should the entry talk about
that yeah it's actually that's actually
an important part of his life story you
know that he had a very rough use and he
could have you know gone down a really
dark path and he turned his life around
that's actually interesting so
categories are tricky
especially with people
because we like to sign labels to people
into ideas somehow and those labels
stick yeah and there's certain words
that have a lot of power like criminal
um like political Left Right Center
um anarchist
objectivist
uh what other philosophies are there
Marxist communist Social Democrat
Democratic Socialist socialist
and like if you add that as a category
all of a sudden it's like oh boy
you're that guy now yeah and I don't
know if you want to be that there's some
definitely some really charged ones uh
like alt-right I think it's quite uh
quite complicated and tough I mean it's
not a completely meaningless label but
boy I think you really have to pause
before you actually put that label on
someone partly because now you're
putting them in a group of people some
of them are quite
you wouldn't want to be grouped with
so it's yeah